okay so the talk would be on
reconstruction of circuits a specific
model of circuits called homogeneous
step three circuits it's a joint work
with Neera to already define the
deconstruction problem but just to make
sure we are on the same page let me go
over it again that I'd let F be an
Nvidia polynomial of degree D and and
suppose it's it can be computed by a
circuit of size s yeah from from a Class
C and the reconstruction problem is the
following given black box access to F
output a small circuit from see yeah
black box access means membership query
exists at you if you give a point to
this black box and put the evaluation of
F at that point so ideally we want the
size of the output circuits to be
polynomially yes s is let's say the size
of the minimum circuit computing F and
we would also like the output circuit to
come from the same class at C so this
notion is called proper learning and
further something to do with the
efficiency of the algorithm ideally
would like the learning algorithm to run
in time polynomial in s and D but even
if the running time is polynomial in the
density presentation of F which is like
polynomial in this big n the number of
monomials in n it can still be
non-trivial because a trivial algorithm
will have to you know go over all
possible sizes circuitry is exponential
in s it can be much larger than the
quantity n when s is between small n n n
okay so unfortunately the construction
turns out to be a hard problem it is at
least as hard as lower bounds because of
the following results verse one is by 49
five ones from 2009 showed the following
that a randomized poly time
reconstruction algorithm for a circuit
plus C implies explicit lower bounds for
the same Class C yes but in particular
it will show the existence of a function
from B P exp the exponential
time version of BBP and vulcan which has
a sort of atomized version of of this
result for you starting from a
deterministic part i will go with them
you you get an explicit functioning exp
policy so it's at least as hard as lower
bound so naturally people focused on the
construction algorithms for those
circuit classes for which lower bounds
non-trivial lower bounds or no no
arithmetic circuits which works also for
RPG yeah also for arithmetic circuits
and you see we therefore for the boolean
circuit that I think it's that they talk
about back learning here instead of
exact learning I mean for this talk all
circuit classes would be arithmetic
circuit classes so there's a slight
difference okay so naturally the the the
converse question is does lower bound
imply efficient learning seems unlikely
because reconstruction is is an
inherently hard problem it's directly
related to approximating the minimum
circuit size the minimum circuit size
problem on the mcsp problem is quite
well studied but it's not as well
understood for boolean circuits and so
falling problem that given a truth table
and an integer S check if the if there
is a function computed by a circuit of
size s that's defined by this truth tub
now this is of course believed not to be
in P but it's not here whether this is
np-complete but what is known from a
result by a lender and hirahara
is that even an approximation version of
the mcsp problem is probably hard hard
in the sense that it's not in poly time
so here's the precise result that let if
silent be some small constant and can be
a really small much smaller than a
constant then approximating the minimum
circuit size within n to the 1 minus
epsilon factor cannot be done in
polynomial time assuming
functions this is this result is just
for the boolean case yes this is just
for the boolean case
yeah nothing for it make circuits yes
yes so it's coming to it so yeah so as
Russell pointed out it's it's for
boolean circuits not for 8 minutes
circuits but we'd like to draw an
analogy between the boolean and the
arithmetic world and like to say that ok
seems like the construction is also hard
even if F is given verbosely as a list
of coefficients so that's the analogy
between truth tables and and polynomials
verbosity presentation of oh yeah so
yeah by analogy it seems like learning
arithmetic circuit is also hot right so
but this doesn't rule out the
possibility that certain kinds of lower
bounds like natural lower bonds might
still imply efficient learning and in
yesterday's talk Marcus already went
through natural clothes which was
proposed by rosboroughs ludecke and the
algebraic versions by Mike I made bulk
of it not what Ben bulk yeah you're sure
mean all mike sex and Shivangi and so
one interesting feature of natural lower
bound is the constructive 'ti feature
which already gives a headway towards
efficient reconstruction that inside the
lower bound is an efficient algorithm
which is at least able to recognize the
fact that EF has low circuit complexity
given the the list of coefficients of F
it would output 0 if F has low
complexity so it's kind of a separator
for this class see our question is
whether one can strengthen this or build
on this kind of separated algorithms and
turn it to a you know full fledged
learning algorithm now this I mean there
are several success stories coming from
the boolean circuit world starting from
the seminal
celebrated work by Lin Ian
Monsoor and Nissan who used the lower
bound natural-born film work for AC zero
circuit to give back learning algorithm
but let me start from the most recent
one by karma see no impact layers of
cabinets and coca-cola Kahlua who used
the natural lower bound framework for AC
0 P circuits to give quasi-polynomial
time back learning algorithm for the
same class and the the the earlier two
results the one for AC 0 and it's easy
to put with poly log majority gates they
are also pack learning quasi-polynomial
time algorithms but let me make a note
that these learning algorithms are not
proper in the sense that the output
let's say for this is not an AC 0
circuit but you know some caused a
poli-sci circuit and same for this one
as well as this one
ok so the net it's a natural and
expression is like can we hope to get
such you know natural lower bound to
reconstructions translations for
arithmetic circuits there are some
favorable results in the arithmetic
world by clive on CH and amish Wilker
and microbes and ax men who gave
efficient reconstruction regardless for
models like auto EBP and non
commutativity pset multi linear AP and
so on and these models do have natural
lower bonds so and and the learning
algorithms are also efficient so that
makes one quite hopeful about it but in
the I Patrick wall there are several
other models for which natural lower
bonds really strong low bonds are known
but no learning algorithm so it's not
clear what the status is the the reason
is like there are a few challenges in
there it might equal the first challenge
is like we have to do exactly learning
for arithmetic circuits and I mean PAC
learning wouldn't make too much sense
here
the reason being two polynomials differ
at far too many points so if the output
is actually a night bike circuit so it's
computing a polynomial so it has to
compute it exactly there are two other
challenges depth reduction and
homogeneous Asian so let me briefly
state here what are the the issues here
and then I'll take up an example to
explain these points more the first
issue is depth reduction here even
constant depth circuits are far more
powerful and the second issue is
homogeneous Asian which makes
reconstruction challenging even for
classes for which exponential natural
lower bonds are not so let me you know
illustrate these two points with the
help of this model homogeneous deputy
circus that's also the subject of this
talk so homogeneous our deputy circuit
computes a polynomial F as a sum of
terms s terms each term is a product of
D linear forms in n variables yeah we'll
call such a circuit NDS homogeneous
degree circuit and there are very good
law bonds not for this model when when D
is less than n there's a lower bound
shown by Nissan and Vic dozen which is
like into the Omega D yeah and even for
higher D like D greater than n one can
show exponential lower bond so for the
whole range of D like starting from
small D to 2 to the N you have very good
lower bonds and these lower bonds are
actually natural yeah so the the obvious
next question is that ok we have very
good natural Lobot so this model can we
do learning for this model and this was
also posed as an as an open problem by
clive and ian's and speaker that whether
we can actually do this now let me state
what we have we have some partial
progress some partial answer to this
question that if n is like omega d
square and s satisfies some mild
condition then there is indeed a
randomized poly NS time algorithm to
reconstruct n D s homogeneous step 3
circuits but not India sahaja nice depth
research it's in full generality but
only non degenerate and that's what
makes this a partial result but we do
proper learning the output is indeed
another depth research it homogeneous
step three circuit and not an arbitrary
circuit but there are two obvious
restriction straight that makes it a
partial result one is the degree
restriction which is
that n is larger than d square and of
course the main restriction which is the
non degeneracy restriction and I'm going
to explain more what this is in the next
slide but let me quickly say that we get
we can ignore this for the moment let's
not pay too much attention to this the
the reason being that we do feel that
this restriction is a technical artifact
coming from from our proof the way we
are arguing it and this this shouldn't
be there like I mean if with some other
kind of proof technique it should be
possible to do it even for larger D and
the underlying main reason being that we
have good lower bounds for a large range
of D so this doesn't quite make sense so
ignore it for the time so this is the
main restriction so the non degeneracy
condition is the following let recall
that F is computed like this yeah so let
K be this quantity log s by log n by D
roughly and you be the eighth order
partial ad space of F and UI be the
space spanned by the Kate order partial
yeah right so then it's obviously clear
that U is contained in in the sum of
this U is the non degeneracy condition
states it has two parts that this sum is
actually a direction and this
containment is an equality yeah of this
two parts we think that this Dirac some
assumption is rather mild the mainly non
degeneracy condition is coming from this
equality yeah why this is milder for
example assume for a moment that s is
poly n if s is poly n then k is a
constant right now notice that if K is
zero then all this is saying that the
without loss of generality I can assume
that T 1 2 TS are linearly independent
right so that's saying like the zeroth
order spaces are they deform at the exam
right so the the now the direction part
of the non-indigenous e condition is
saying that all we want is that the
direction
conditioned to hold up to some constant
key yeah k0 is like without loss of
generality we want this up to some
constant key right so the Equality is
the main source of non-linearity which
okay so yeah one can show that random
homogenize homogeneous step three
circuit is almost surely non degenerate
in this particular sense this equality
holds for some K does it hold for other
case smaller larger larger the base k
equal to zero you say this k equal to
zero is without loss of generality so
higher is like stronger a putting
stronger restriction if it holds for
some K implies smaller K also yes that's
correct so yeah so naturally like so
this doesn't entirely answer the
question posed by clive and ian's Bilka
and so the question is whether we can
get rid of non Legion is entirely and
completely answer their question for a
moment if you believe that we that we
are able to do this let's see what are
the consequences and this will also help
me explain those two issues you have to
find the minimum the minimum sized
circuit but reconstruction is a yeah so
it's like an approximating the minimum
size right yeah she can go but so this
condition is no integer in particular
does it apply uniqueness of
representation in some sense sorry this
condition does it imply uniqueness of
representation only right it does it
does yeah it does yes
so as I think needed mentioned in his
talk but the proof implies that the
circuit that you'll get is unique the
next question is can you get away it was
just as you main uniqueness or you need
actually to no degeneracy good question
but it's not here like just assuming
that there's a the circuit is unique
that the unique si circuits not clear
clear whether we can do reconstruction
arithmetic circuit depth change maybe
hardness result yeah I think that there
are this one I remember by cliven CH and
someone else on but there was a PAC
learning under any distribution and not
uniform distribution so they showed the
PAC learning under arbitrary
distribution is hard yeah for dep three
arithmetic circuits not for yeah and not
also not for uniform distribution
general random circuits so not not dep
three or anything yeah it's not clear
even for depth
but they'll give it up to a constant
change one plus Epsilon yeah because
reconstruction allows polyester eight so
you can go but this hardness result by
climbers that's also holds for paulius
but it was for back learning under Union
okay so saw the consequences are the
following the first consequence is like
if you could do the same thing without
non degeneracy that would imply a lower
bound for depth arithmetic circuit which
is not known yet by a simple
homogenization trick that suppose F is
computed by an NDA step three circuit
then you can homogenize it and this
homogeneous polynomial would be computed
by a homogeneous depth recirc it in one
more variable and the thus will get an
efficient reconstruction for depth three
circuits which in turn will imply a
lower bound for the same class because
you know learning implies reconstruction
we already saw learning implies level
yes
this but this would be beep exp but this
would still be some sort of explicitly
urban the existence of a function in VP
exp the title connection is won by bulk
which like if you get deterministic then
you can actually compute a polynomial in
exp or multi linear polynomial the
proofs are along the same line yeah the
proofs are quite similar but yeah right
the second consequence is that this will
also imply reconstruction for general
circuits and that's because of depth
reduction results by several people
starting from Agarwal Vinay in Pascal
Sebastian Ram Prasad leaders petition ok
it will have a huge degree and that's
but it the degree will still be some
exponential it won't be it would be like
n to the Rudy and that's what I say like
you can perhaps ignore this degree
restriction so that this seems to be a
technical we believe that the same thing
should be possible assuming just non
degeneracy but even for much larger D if
you you know change the you know lifting
the template might be the same but some
other means it doesn't seem to be a like
a fundamentally restriction to us okay
so can you just increase it arbitrarily
where it's not the number of variables n
is the number of variables yes so can
you just introduce dummy variables which
need not be generous see might affect
that right
polynomial in D as well as ironic time
will be increased to play key forever s
is like right so the running time will
have now be polynomial in D yeah it was
already the case yeah yeah so I think
just homogenizing will probably not do
anything with the non degeneracy
condition if I just replace the rate in
variable X I by summation Y IJ is son
I've got lots of variables yeah but
something I I don't know what would
happen
yeah oh I see that way like just to
increase the number of variables okay if
they are too small okay oh yeah yeah so
then that then yeah then the nod
nondegenerate condition won't hold it
will fail so sorry I
I came so you so not sure I understood
the question yeah so then but then
that's what I'm saying then this
condition won't hold this equality won't
would you propose doesn't change not you
look you I okay so okay so let's see so
you're saying that you use lots of dummy
variables yeah
right okay
another way to look at this you
multiplied the entire circuit by like Z
1 Z 2 Z 3 Z 4 z 5 z whatever fresh new
variables and then you look at all these
new variables yeah so that's a Mondrian
that I mean this another way is also
much simpler you're saying like those
dummy variables are there it's but the
spaces won't change right so that's what
you're saying is figuring in Mikey yes
yeah the answer is reasonably simple
let me think think about okay but yeah
so that reason we made this non
degenerate this condition that n is
greater than 3 D square is to make this
non-designer AC condition hold for with
high probability for random circuits so
yeah so otherwise so that's right so it
will give the construction even for
general circuits of exponential time
reconstruction and thus we believe that
in an unconditional translation for from
natural lower bounds to efficient
reconstruction seems extremely
challenging in the arithmetic world even
for the three circuits natural lower
bound proofs as per a ludic and the
algebraic versions of it and if you
believe that the constructs of
exponential time reconstruction for
general circuits is not possible then
perhaps this translation is also not
possible unconditionally what might be
possible though is that we might be able
to use this natural lower bound
framework yeah of this model to do
efficient reconstruction for the same
model under some non degeneracy
condition that also originates from this
lower bound proof it's not like at every
line
arbitrary non degeneracy condition the
non recent condition also rises from the
natural proof lower bound and let me
also illustrate this point using our non
determinacy condition that for
homogeneous depth three circuit the
natural lower bound by Nissan we doesn't
the one crucial aspect of it was that
each UI is simple in the sense that it's
a low dimensional space and but the non
region is a condition is trying to do it
is trying to exploit this fact that UI
is simple and translating the
reconstruction problem or reducing it to
decomposing the space you into these
simple spaces so that's what the liquid
the non-religion is a condition and
that's how it is helping us yeah but a
project is not clear how to do this
decomposition whether this this is
possible at all efficiently and therein
lies the contribution of this work we
show that this is possible and in in
doing this we also proposed this
paradigm that leaders was talking about
in the morning the paradigm for handling
large Fanning gates which appears to be
the main difficulty of reconstruction
problems so there's this the paradigm in
two steps that first we reduce the
problem of finding children of some gate
to a decomposition problem and in our
case that decompose that this first step
turns out to be quite trivial it it
follows directly from the non degenerate
condition yet so you reduce with this to
this decomposition problem and the
second step is you actually decompose
this do this decomposition by
considering an space of linear operators
acting on you yeah and the struck use
the structure of you to somehow
decompose do this decomposition and the
precise structure that we use is the
irreducible invariant spaces of you
induced by yes so I'm going to talk
about this now in a moment but yeah
that's the template and yeah as he also
mentioned that we feel that the paradigm
do have the potential to give other
reconstruction results as wrong he was
mentioning the construction for random
dep
random circuits in general not sure
whether that is possible but we
be for those models for which lower
bones are known one might be able to do
it assuming then the average case kind
of stuff right so prior work on
efficient reconstruction like out of AP
non except these models are a VP
non-community VP indeed ones formulas
most of the other models to assume that
that the findings of the some gates are
very small either constant or they work
only for up to n or n square kind of
stuff so this is a good time to also
review some of the related works just to
show why they work with you know not why
that they do work when the fanning out
some gates s1 starting with this work by
beam al Berg autonomous UT crucial area
chain who gave a randomized
reconstruction for symmetric tensors and
and general tenses and the the same
argument cliven change Pilger saw that
this can be this also gives an algorithm
a reconstruction algorithm for general
depth research so it's no longer
efficient it's exponential in d the
output these algorithms are not proper
learning because the output is an RVP
and not depth a circuit then I'm a gave
reconstruction over finite fields for
depth three circuits with tough and into
this is a quasi poly time algorithm was
extended to like constant fanon yeah
again over a finite field and they also
didn't um is the algorithm in the
process then god of gave a randomized
reconstruction for dep 3 again with fan
to but overall sort or rationals running
in poly time okay and these algorithms
are proper yeah modular small the
condition
there also there is also one algorithm
known for depth for circuits under the
assumption of Multan unity and also
fanning to but often in two and that's
also poly time ago this is also proper
there are a few reconstruction
algorithms known assuming non degeneracy
condition the there are a couple for
depth repowering circuits or symmetric
tensors one by needed the other by
Garcia Marko Pascal and Picatta
so the second one which is more recent
is better than the first one in the
regime when these much smaller than s so
then this is caused a poly as this is
poly there are also reconstruction
algorithms for more general models as
assuming non degeneracy conditions one
is by hunky tears and huming who gave
randomized reconstruction for regular
formulas with finding two Degla formulas
formulas where the fine of the of the
gates at every level are equal and
earlier this year we gave a randomized
deconstruction an algorithm for constant
width homogeneous EVPs now let me put
the last two results in the context of
lower bound so it I mean remember that
we get learning only for models for
which lower bounds are known so far I
mean this has always been the case just
to put this result in context of our
bonds that regular formulas to have a
super polynomial lower bound so on and
the second one like men'll showed a
linear with lower bound for homogeneous
AVP so that's why I mean these lower
ones already indicate that these are
weak models so probably you can do
learning okay so that's it we can now go
back to homogeneous depth recirculating
describe their goal any questions so far
almost time do we have
it's okay all right so the outline of
the algorithm is very simple that the
step one you compute the basis of you
and step two you decompose that's the
main step and step three you find the
individual terms from from the US so
what do you mean by the decomposition
that you from the basis of who you find
basis of this individual spaces and
everything happens in the black box
setting I might not explicitly mention
this black box but okay so the first
step and the third steps are relatively
easy so let me quickly go over it that
we want to compute a space a basis of
you and that's that's because given F
you can compute its derivative in the in
the black box setting and you do this K
times K being small you only have to I
mean the number of elements in this set
the gate order derivatives of F is also
small so you find all of them and then
find a basis of it that also you can do
in the black box because of the second
fact so that's the that's how you do
step one and at the end of step one we
get a basis of you yeah so let let's
remember that this is gamma and U is a
space of dimension M now let's see how
to do step three step two I'll come
later so but when step two finishes we
already have basis of this individual
uise yeah and let the these basis
elements be these right now define the
set degree K to be the set of all degree
K monomials
in the in the underlying set of
variables yeah okay so now set up this
equations which would essentially boil
down to solving a system of linear
equations so for every alpha in a degree
K monomial you set this equation up
pretending that these C's are variables
and
we have black box access to all the g's
as well as the f right so using this you
can solve this linear system just by you
know evaluating the GS and the
derivative of F at different points and
you solve for all the seats yeah once
you solve for all the C's then notice
that for every I right so this is what
would be satisfied so we are basically
using the basis of the the UI's to get
access to the derivatives of the of the
tea is all of them and and this is how
you do it because you do it for each and
every alpha and the reason this is this
holds is because again because of the
non degeneracy condition because of the
Dirac some structure of the u-ace yeah
so once you solve the sea-ice you you
get the derivative of the tea is for for
all alpha you put them together using
this nice well-known formula to get TI
and which holds for any homogeneous
polynomial it doesn't have to be product
of linear forms yeah any homogenous
formula yeah so from the derivatives you
can get the polynomial that's it so we'd
like to thank God of for showing out
this precise our given our the earlier
argument for step three was slightly
longer than this it was along the same
lines but slightly longer okay so now
let's come to the main step which is
step two for this I'll quickly go over
some basic definitions so let let u be a
space and s a space of linear operators
on you we say V which is a subspace of U
is an invariant subspace if s maps
Vettori and moreover V is irreducible
if you can't split it further into
invariant spaces which means that
there's no invariant subspace properly
continually we also define closure of a
vector with respect to this space of
operators s it's the smallest invariant
space of u containing V that's a closure
of a vector and from the definition it's
easy to see that are not too hard to see
that
okay given a V and a basis of s because
s is a space of operators a basis you
can represent by matrices
yeah I'm given this set of matrices and
B you can just keep applying these
matrices on V until it is closed and
until you get the space you can no
longer grow and that gives you the
closure of V and this can be done in
deterministic poly time so yeah that's
it that's a background so now let's go
into the actual decomposition step so
the main idea is to so far we haven't
told you what's the choice of the space
of operators we choose the space of
operators carefully so that these
individual u is they turn out to be the
irreducible invariant subspaces of you
induced by s so the decomposition is
unique in the sense it's a unique
irreducible decomposition of of U and
the second step is you find this
decomposition and the way you find it so
you pick a vector or different vectors
in you carefully such that the closures
of this vectors with respect to s will
give you this space as you want rhiness
that's the idea and let's see how to
make this idea what you can of course
you can view this as a simultaneous
block diagonalization step ok so the
choice of the space of derivatives is
the following so you consider all kate
order derivatives multiply them by kate
degree monomials yeah go over all
possible choice of alpha and beta yeah
and look at the space spanned by them
yeah over F that's the set of shifted
differential operators and s is a subset
of them or a subspace of this space
consisting of only those operators or
shifted differentials that map you to
you yeah so so that's that's the
definition of this and it turns out and
again it's not too hard to show that you
can actually compute a basis of s from a
basis of you recall that we already have
a basis of U from the first step we have
already computed it and I'm skipping
over this one one can you know easily
like before one can say
a system of linear equations and get a
basis of this space of operator disease
yeah so by the end of it we have a basis
of hesse and let's see how to use it but
before using it let me list a few
properties of s which will help in the
proof I'm not going to prove any of
these but these these are the crucial
properties which which actually helps in
in giving us the decomposition the first
thing that you want to us are indeed
invariant subspaces of you under induced
by this choice of s and second is that
they exist
operator shy having distinct eigenvalues
in this space s and the third claim is a
strengthening of the first claim that
not only these are invariant subspaces
of you induced by is there these are
actually irreducible ingredients of
speakers yes so I'm not going to prove
these claims there this is where the
technical bit goes into but let us use
this to give the decomposition you got
it
how much time
seven minutes okay so any questions so
far
so can you see me using a stove I mean
not Miriam this would be that you would
think just differential operators would
have been enough but oh but taking
derivatives the degrees one master it
will take so it won't be a differential
operation from you to you take you to a
smaller degree differential space so so
from the first step we have a basis and
we already know how to compute a basis
of the space of operators yeah and this
operators can be naturally associated
with matrices because the basis of U is
fixed once you fix a basis you you can
actually is every operator in s with a
with a matrix yeah so these M gamma shy
eyes are the corresponding matrices so
you first pick a random operator from
the space just by picking random
elements from F and taking their linear
combination yes and compute the
characteristic polynomial of this random
operator factor it completely if if it
is not a square free factorization then
you all could fail yeah otherwise you
factor yeah and so we'll look at the the
correctness of the algorithm in the next
slide and now you compute null spaces of
these factors evaluated at the random
operator yeah and pride it's not clear
what this null spaces are supposed to
give and pick vectors from this null
spaces now yeah any one of them not far
from each of these null spaces and
compute the closure of these vectors
with respect to the your original space
s of operators right so and that's it
that's the algorithm and these closures
are supposed to be our you eyes so
that's the claim yeah so let me go over
it again as I go over it I'll also
analyze it yeah so as I said like this
is just picking a random operated in s
and why is that this random operator
would the characteristic polynomial of
it would be square free with high
probability that
because of the second claim that there
exists an operator shy in the space with
having distinct eigenvalues and one can
show that this implies that a random
operator will also have distinct eigen
values and hence the the characteristic
paranoia would be square-free yeah and
now the claim is that the null spaces of
these these factors evaluated at this
random operator these null spaces are
contained in the UI's right so although
I've used a slightly different notation
here but this this is exactly the space
you I I'm just distinguishing with a
different notation because UI is a space
of polynomials and once you fix gamma
this is the corresponding space of you
know vectors in lying in F to the M
that's all yeah because this the spaces
are not spaces of polynomials but spaces
of you know vectors in F to be so and
and that's the main claim that we have
to prove that this null spaces are
contained in this if I and now it's over
because once you know that these null
spaces are actually spaces inside the
UI's you just pick a vector and if you
compute the closure you're going to get
you I right because it's irreducible
that's the third claim that because they
are irreducible you are going to get the
whole thing and nothing more nothing
less
right so so all we are left with is to
prove that this null spaces are indeed
contained in the you guys yeah okay and
that would be the end of the talk okay
so let me quickly go over it that the
statement does not quite depend on the
choice of the basis so I'm going to
prove it with a you know easier choice
of basis which is that gamma is found by
taking unions of basis of u1 through us
yeah and with this every operator in s
would be block diagonal right because
the U is are invariant spaces so the map
UI to UI so it would be block diagram
and PIB occur with the characteristic
polynomial of RI right so so that means
the characteristic polynomial of the
whole entire operator is a product of
this which we know is also a product of
this coming from the algorithm yeah so
which means that a
J divided some PA yeah so we're going to
show that for this choice of J and I ng
is contained in the corresponding UI so
the choice of I gets fixed here for the
rest of the proof so now pick a vector
in ng so I have to show that this vector
also belongs to you I so apply the
polynomial P I on on this operator it
operates like this and then multiplied
with the vector V and feel valued to 0
the reason being that AJ divides P I and
V is in the null space of a J M gamma
right so that's why this left hand side
is 0 so this is 0 so you what you you
think of V as a column vector
yes Plitt it up into s segments we want
to V s the V 1 corresponds to the
segment for u 1 and so on so you wish to
prove or we wish to prove here that all
the segments here are 0 except VI 1
meant okay thanks so I'm done so so yeah
so it's a very simple linear algebra for
me so let me click over it so this gives
P I R Q times V Q equal to 0 for every Q
yeah so now pick a Q which is not I you
wish to show that the Q is 0 right and
all we have is p ir q PQ is 0 so because
H is square free there would be
polynomials II 1 e 2 such that this
holds so evaluate this equation at our Q
this vanishes because PQ is the
characteristic polynomial of our Q and
then multiply both sides by the vector V
Q and that's that's 0 because this is 0
coming from here so that means if you
choose Q not equal to i it would be 0
and so the only thing that would be left
in V is V I which means that we would be
in
so it's a simple proof set the summary
is that yeah so we give a reconstruction
algorithm a partial answer to the
problem posed by clive and ian's speaker
reckons and our reconstruction algorithm
is strongly influenced by the natural
proof framework of Nissan big dozen and
as well as the non legionary condition
and in doing so the we you know came up
with this paradigm which we feel that
might be applicable elsewhere the choice
of the space was shifted differential
space and I would like to close with
these open problems that can we do
reconsider
paradigm to other models like homogenous
depth for circuits constant at multi
linear circuits tabular formulas multi
linear formulas for all of these models
very good lower bounds are known all of
them are national or bonds so can we
apply this and do reconstruction
assuming nonlinear AC yeah that's it
thank you so there's a sense why the
desire brake setting we are always
getting proper learning outcomes and
somehow I mean in the boolean setting
the difference is pretty noticeable and
here we seem to not as you mean non
degeneracy we are getting I think that
because of the uniqueness of the
circuits but if you don't assume non
degeneracy then even for depth
repowering circuits the the learning
algorithm gives you an array VP which is
much higher
okay so they do is this um assuming
knowledge engine not these abrasive
actually get the smallest circuit for it
but I mean yes yeah it the proof tells
you that the circuit is also unique
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]